[Music]
we've scoured the city for the hottest
new fitness disciplines these are the
workouts everyone's talking about
we've got turf set white-eye tabata yoga
and boot camp it's your body now this is
fighting me I am will and this is Tabata
this is your at home Tabata warmup hey
guys so today we're gonna start with a
warm-up for everybody out there that
wants to get into shape wants to get
ripped this is where you start first so
he's gonna run us through a little bit
of a warm-up series and pay attention
first one we're gonna do is be walking a
line also known as the Samsung stretch
it's gonna help get your hips loose I
also open up your shoulders so that
first thing you look at you should take
a wide step out
imagine your feet are on a railroad
track not a tightrope so if you're on a
tightrope
you're kind of losing your balance you
wanna be on a railroad track you're nice
and wide you're gonna stretch it down
dropping your hips down so you're gonna
feel a nice stretch on these hip flexor
and you're gonna stretch up and back so
you should feel a nice stretch
you'll stand and take another step out
you do this about ten times on each leg
the inchworm
so you'll reach down touch your toes
keep your legs as straight as possible
you're gonna inch your hands out you're
gonna go through downward dog you're
done yoga I have totally gonna Goods
through okay so you get the nice
abdominal stretch you'll push back into
down dog to open up your shoulders and
calves and then you'll inch your feet in
back to that hamstring stretch stand and
then you'll do it again five to ten
times next up we have high knees
so then I'll are going to get our heart
rate up a little bit you never want to
start a high intensity workout without
already having a little bit of sweat
going okay you just want to do knees as
high as you can
but kicks for 20 seconds you just want
to kick your feet to your hands work on
activating your quads so you're slamming
your feet down to the ground you can
alternate through those again high knees
cool now for about 20 seconds shake it
out
alright guys so to recap this is your
at-home two bottle warm up walking lunge
or are also known as the Samsun stretch
the inchworm
in high knees for 20 seconds butt kicks
for 20 seconds should be nice and warm
and ready for any workout good let's go
make sure to subscribe so you don't miss
out on any other fighting weight
episodes
[Music]